Krispy Kreme outdoes itself and every other bakery in the world.
I'm Mara Montalbano for Buzz60.
We've all heard of the 300-dollar burger,...
...the 1,000-dollar ice cream sundae...
...and the 10,000-dollar martini.
Well, here's the latest edible treat that just might be too rich for your blood...
...in more ways than one.
It almost looks too good to eat. Almost.
It actually doesn't even look like a donut at all,...
...more like something you'd wear on your head to a royal wedding.
Krispy Kreme in the UK has unveiled the most expensive donut in the world.
The costly confection is made with edible 24-karat gold leaf,...
...decorated with edible diamonds and filled with a vintage Dom Perignon champagne jelly.
And to wash it down, a cocktail made with that same champagne...
...and a 500-year-old Courvoisier cognac.
So what does it cost?
About 1,000 British pounds or $1,600 US.
It was an exclusive for a charity event and was presented to a lucky contest winner...
...who is probably trying to figure out...
...how to wear it for a little while before she eats it.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.